استعد للتواصل ولمس ما
فواتير AT&T
كأول هاتف فيديو موشن للحركة الملونة للمنزل ، وتساءل
عن شكل والدتك عندما
تشرح أنك لن تحضر لتناول العشاء أو
ماذا عن رئيسك في العمل
عندما تتأخر في الصباح.  أن تكون قادرًا على
اكتشاف بغض النظر عما قد تكون
سمعته ، فنحن لا نغير الاسم القانوني لشركة 18 T
إلى شركات الهاتف والتلفزيون الأمريكية ،
لكن ما نقوم
به هو تغيير طبيعة
الاتصالات اليوم ، استعد
للتواصل والتعامل مع فواتير AT&T باعتبارها
أول هاتف فيديو متحرك ملون
للمنزل كعرض توضيحي استخدمت AT&T الممثلين
روبرت واجنر وجيل ستريت.  جون في لوس
أنجلوس ليرى ابنته
كاتي في نيويورك والتحدث معها ، أعتقد أنها
بالتأكيد نهاية المواعدة في
بداية نوع آخر من المواعدة
الخجولة وأي شخص آخر يريد الخصوصية
يمكنه قلب الغالق لمنع الكاميرا
ولكن بعض الأشخاص تريد من AT&T
ألا تبيع طواعية أيًا من هواتف الفيديو إلى
تسعمائة رقم خط جنسي ، يمكنك
فقط تخيل قدرة الأطفال غير الخاضعين للإشراف
على الاتصال أو الرقم 900 الذي
سمعناه عن الهواتف المصورة منذ
المعرض العالمي في منتصف الستينيات.
تمكنا من رؤية والتحدث مع بعضنا
البعض مؤخرًا من خلال
استخدام المؤتمرات عن بعد للأعمال التجارية قفز
بشكل كبير بسبب الخوف من
الإرهاب أثناء حرب الخليج
والتكلفة المنخفضة مقابل تحليق الفارق الكبير
هنا في المنزل ، لا توجد
معدات خاصة يمكنك توصيلها
مقبس الحائط القياسي
سيكون سعر مكالمة الهاتف المرئي هو نفسه سعر
المكالمة الهاتفية العادية ولكن
سيكلف الجهاز حوالي 1500 دولار ، وبالطبع
سيستغرق الأمر شخصين للتحدث عن pi  cture على الرغم من
أنه ليس أفضل 10 إطارات ، فهو النوع
الثاني مثل التحدث إلى
رواد فضاء مكوك مبكر ، وإذا كان لديك 60
قناة تلفزيونية في المنزل ، فقد
تشعر بالملل من WAV للقيام بشيء ما ، لكن
المحللين التقنيين يعتقدون أنه انقلاب كبير في
التقنيات التي جمعوها معًا
يشبه وضع كل المياه من
خرطوم إطفاء الحرائق عبر خرطوم الحديقة ،
إنه لأمر مدهش الضغط على هذا النوع المرئي كثيرًا
Meishan هو ما أعتقد أن الناس يحتاجون إليه
تلفزيون الكابل ومذيعي التلفزيون عبر
خط هاتف عادي ، سيُطرح هاتف الفيديو
للبيع في مايو.  عالم نعيش فيه
أعتقد أنهم
سيجدون ريتشارد روث سي إن إن نيويورك أسرع بكثير